that Martha girl did make a good point
that in different cultures like in this
in the Spanish La Latin culture and in
the Asian culture if you put on a few
pounds your grandma will go you're
getting chunky you need to watch
yourself whereas in in modern Western
culture and Eastern Europe they like
when I was you know in Eastern Europe
they'll be like oh yeah they go over to
Tommy they're the fat guy they'll be
like if that was this country oh you
can't call someone fat well that's a
fact the dude's overweight y you know my
ltrr is French and her grandma was just
like you need to stop eating so much
and that's like you know in in Western
culture you know in America here like
Stacy and Becky will will tell Jen that
she looks awesome when she's 30 pounds
overweight yeah I I almost wonder if
that's to disqualify them from being
competitive on the sexual Marketplace
like oh yeah you know you keep eating
because you're beautiful at any weight
like it's almost like if I can get this
chick fat enough then she'll have no
competition within the circle that I
roll with exactly always Victoria Secret
just back down on that sorry off go
ahead no it's just well people try to
flip that around and they say Well then
why do other then why do you help other
men or why do other men help each other
because the more competent virtuous
attractive men in the dating pool the
worse your
odds and it's different because men have
always depended on each other to be
strong and virtuous and fellow leaders
to move society and their tribe forward
so even though you are introducing
competition sort of into the mating
pool the benefits that the tribe gets
are the benefit that Society gets from
having strong masul men around her is a
net positive where there's not that same
need for women to be baned together
their Sisterhood is largely sort of this
it it's such a there's a huge jposition
it's such sort of a a mind [__] when you
talk about The Sisterhood because on one
hand it's about you know girl power and
protecting and things like that but yeah
there's there's no reason for women to
be honest with one another because
they're all competing for a very small
percentage of men and having other
attractive women to compete against them
doesn't offer any sort of positive
benefit there's also the reinforcement
from the S Community too because it's
not just women that lie to women it's
also men that lie to women right like um
you remember when we had that girl on
that was talking about her book mooff
you know on the lady's night and she
wanted to be recognized for her
accomplishments as a strong successful
woman as an author you know as a
successful accountant blah blah blah and
then on her Instagram she's got pictures
of her ass everywhere right but it's
like you know she she just couldn't
fathom a world you know in which men
would only or or generally appreciate
her you know first and foremost for her
beauty and but subconsciously she knows
it's true because every photo on her
Instagram was pictures of her body
exposed body parts and they're all like
that we've had multiple women that have
come on and say I want to be know I have
this many degrees and I'm this good at
this and I can do all the man housew
work too but you go in their profile
it's just ass and they also get like
guys dming them going oh girl you know
your degree is so hot don't listen to
those guys in the show it's like loser
that's the thing like we come on and
every now and then we'll have a pretty
significant we had a pretty significant
breakthrough with the guest I think a
couple weeks back and you know she
really opened up in the last sort of 10
minutes of the show and then any
progress or any sort of introspection
that may have been done by us was
completely undone by a half dozen dudes
in her DMS telling her that we're wrong
or that not all guys are like that or
[__] like that
and I think I
think I think anybody who says not all
guys are like that's one of the weakest
statements a man could say or I'm not
like the other guys that's literally
that's literally saying I'm going to be
at the blue oyster tonight you know
doing you know what if anyone can get
the yeah it's basically creep game like
there's like there's all kind of
different game out there and that's
basically creep gamer there's another
one they call um what is it the dirty
[__] or sneaky [__] game where like
yeah yeah there's like this thing called
sneaky [__] game where in where in the
animal kingdom like basically sneaky
[__] especially in like eight type of
communities will go in and try to
pretend you know to be one other or even
try to be female and they'll go in and
they'll mate with other females and kind
of like Zip out they'll go and zip in
quick for the bang and then zip out real
fast before the alpha finds out and
knocks a [__] out of them like there's
sneaky [__] game in every part of the
animal kingdom too right I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out